hey I'm Josh Wolf and I'm Jacob wolf and
this is family tussle the father-son
competition show where the loser has to
do an embarrassing punishment
go
hey Mom
um well I'm about to get into an ax
throwing competition with Dad so do you
have any like words of wisdoms or advice
I will go try to find his Edibles I
guess I love you okay I love you right
he's definitely in big trouble I'm
really not nervous about this
contest at all he's gonna try and get
into my head and while I'm throwing I
know he's just gonna he's gonna try and
yell some things from the background so
he can't get into my head
I got him up here
just be careful my man this ax is sharp
[Music]
all right man well so I'm going into
this competition today with with pops
you have any words of advice or any
words the first thing you need to do is
slow down oh okay all right all right
and you're a little too tall never work
on it okay
better all right you competing with your
dad yep doesn't matter he's old you ever
throwing an ax yes so what are you
talking to me for
first thing you got to do is have
confidence yep okay gotta be short you
gotta talk slow and you gotta have
confidence copy yeah
Trey the reason I picked you as my coach
is because I know you're from the south
so I'm sorry oh yeah you're really good
with the outdoors stereotypical I don't
know it's like redneck Woods yeah do you
have any uh tips yeah just be his dad
you know do dad [ __ ] so mentally torture
him yeah maybe if I'm making noise
yeah like a war cry or just like a yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
oh no yeah yeah okay
we're gonna have three rounds okay
you ready oh I'm ready you keep talking
slow down
go ahead
why does he insist on staying so tall
no matter how many times you're telling
maybe next time we'll watch the hike
you're a little shorter
right there nailed it come on yeah use
your elbow you nailed it over rotated it
if we're judging they're judging on
accuracy neither one's stuck no yes kind
of both losing right now yeah
as a Jewish father I thought I would
teach my son about our traditions
so on this try we're going to dress like
rabbis and we're gonna circumcise a pen
that's how my dad did it
just so you know everybody's watching
why'd you stay out of my boy's head
well he's gonna have to throw it at that
head so I'm just trying to help so just
don't I don't want you to choke on this
it's really important
hey Josh yeah you know you've been doing
like kind of bad yeah I was thinking on
this one like maybe trying to do good
you know
stand behind you
there you go
like that
That's My Boy no more urinary tract
infections for that guy
hey so round three uh could also be a
weird only fans page we are uh Justin's
babies
um and we would like some milk we're
gonna try to get some milk out of there
very hot balance whoa whoa checking to
see if you got a load watch yourself
looks like you got a load watch yourself
yeah same to you it looks to get one on
the front and the back actually so I do
have a load in the front not the right
one about that nope win it oh have you
ever seen those nipples that have that
one long hair that's what you just
chopped off
nailed it
stuck it though yep
and you know I felt it left a little bit
to be desired I mean I thought we did
great judging it uh but you know yeah we
were good yeah now back in 72 in the
Soviet Union they would have shot both
of them I just don't understand why we
got a big tit and a big old dick up
there I mean the boob was huge but and I
like that the dick was life-sized so I
get that
life's something Jesus yeah well if my
stat sheet here is correct it would
appear Josh stuck more than Jacob by a
margin of like
one to zero yeah these two are not cut
out for ax throwing they're they're
absolutely more cut out to ax catch I
think in terms of your accuracy sucked
wasn't much form sucked uh uh and then
style you know if you call perverse and
culturally insensitive style then yeah
you guys
[Music]
we talked about sticking only one person
stuck it I think I Gotta Give it to Josh
we really wanted you to both lose but
they did both lose
I would say that Jacob
you
have disappointed me
I know that feeling
again
I know that feeling too
unfortunately
relax over here all right unfortunately
you lose I came into this without a
doubt you ask anybody in here I was like
he's gonna nail this I've thrown an ax
with him before he's super coordinated
he's long I thought I was gonna have to
get into your head a little bit I was
surprised that yours bounced off I'm
happy they did but I want to let you
know dude I was I really thought that
this one was going to be you yeah I kind
of thought this one was in the bag if I
got to be so honest with you I didn't
think you were gonna be able to cut the
skin off that dick but uh well done
well done go ahead congratulations
hello I love you too I'm not gonna
decided for this punishment
I spent all the money I made this money
on bottled water anybody want to help me
out
like what you see you want a tip no
that was a bad one
you ever see the Charleston like this
feel free to tip guys try to turn on
cheat ladies and gentlemen I gotta fun
this
oh I appreciate it maybe there's
something right in there I appreciate
you man thank you so much
no one on the corner got swagger like me
ah come on nobody
the other Soulja Boy right
now Superman yo
nope
this was the worst thing I've ever done
[Music]